there once was a man and then there was
another one and then there were sunset
riders I'm I'm a little disappointed man
hey let's take out a welcome sunsets
right that's lovely purple boots bury me
I suppose
my name is Steve is you see about this
no that's me see I know my golden hair
how I get all the ladies but about this
gem it's got golden here to this Billy
belly's golden hair is fake as an
implant Oh planted hair you can get that
Club is a [ __ ] bomb steve is my MN
hey I've got a bundle as Christ that is
me I am a car mondo perfect
we are the sunset riders we died almost
offended sunset weird I even if it's not
the sunset we done right haha
this is the rod of the question we can't
write no sunset you've got to be kidding
me
all right two players to know one player
okay no wait that's terrible idea to
play it you got it
either it doesn't work I'll do it oh I
like how that way all right I'll be
going I know I haven't come up Inc I
wanna be king I am the glory ma I am
good what how did you do this I am good
man
I'm Steven her golden hairs are [ __ ] you
I don't even know how to be late whoo
that guy looks like it snorted blood
he's [ __ ] scary this game this is a
ketchup swindler the amnesia monster in
the human form all right gun right cut
her mom cut Amanda has a shot look at
these one of those battles doing
am I wearing a thong you got a man that
doesn't like it
come on who loves my thang shut up
Oh what are you doing this week really
look at this slide my bad guy
thank you okay all right how do I shoot
what was the week oh I don't shoot green
bullet yes
what one rah oh yes
come on door what are you doing take
prison war
come on oh you're badass I'm so good
yeah you don't even notice how do I job
all right there we go we got to jump
over there okay
not a barrel yeah Oh what the how do I
had a help what I don't know oh well yes
come on knock out a man mm all right
yeah you gotta shoot all these innocent
people
oh they can run that day good mind and
take the chicken okay good job oh that's
what nah ah we are really I'm very good
at this take the lemon squeeze I got a
lemon squeeze those $2,000 of lemon holy
[ __ ] that's expensive lemon tea out of
my oh I got Danny Martha's what sonic
Amanda damn it Steve does not know how
to throw down that diet [ __ ]
get up digress press Start on the hell I
ever turned I'm doing with Kayla Jegan
yeah Oh watch it blow it on huh I'm
[ __ ] too many things in life shoots a
ball of us fighting your ball [ __ ] you I
love you good Amanda
have I ever told you that oh I am going
to leave you
nah wait don't feel your way out of that
oh come on I'll get your [ __ ] together I
got the dynamite now okay careful out
from the water hi drum you're pressing
are you anyone where holy [ __ ] I'll come
back keep sure they cut Amanda I dodged
I did you see that you did I done shut
again actually you're buying work but
I'm so good at this game
that's my oh wow
alright don't invite back Amanda I'm
good not gonna react ready for any karma
holy [ __ ] you're rich commander I know
how do you kill the chicken I'm trying
to be one without our loose [ __ ] oh yeah
yeah come on oh yeah yes this is good oh
[ __ ] I fell I forgot to not to ride the
bullets come on
I'm sorry but I gotta bees running holy
[ __ ] help oh no it's been mad at running
oh and it whoa
Carmen are you sharpening your blade get
my sharpening my ha ha
oh sorry got this bro good job scars yes
battle like that has time to look like
smiley faces on them all right you see
that they're actually innocent
if they don't believe their beautiful
smiles oh sorry
alright yep I'm not really gonna get
spells I wouldn't you're sure there's so
much more badass not even fair Salem I
am come on oh oh alright posit skin from
don't even what [ __ ] her I you're doing
everything I don't like this oh my god I
know where I am still Liza okay I did
think that Steve no as golden haired
side don't think all the back open here
doesn't really help you very much well I
have Golan panties and Anna thong
that's gross like how many life that we
have here I don't know I keep dying
I know game over for me come on come on
oh you gotta do it
kuranda forward I'm out of it I'm out of
it you gotta kill him
all right so does anything I'm clapping
for Ian go cry come on you gotta cry
thank you okay keep clapping
I'm sorry come on oh no never
[ __ ] that it's our money now [ __ ]
is he wearing lipstick oh [ __ ] carp why
are you so badass I'm M being you so
much cry you have
look at that post I got embarrassed I
kind of like it's not the lipstick that
is man but it's all with this heart and
that hangs cat Phil he sells propane
our names are Steve my name is Steven oh
I got a mono is fine yeah pero uh oh
right I Horace okay alright starting
over everything we should have used
savestates it's cheating
Garmin Oh does not cheat I'm sick of you
and your commander [ __ ]
shut the [ __ ] up it's my commander come
on huh
I worked above he's eating some he's a
[ __ ] cannibal
he's Simon listening
are we really doing this again I'm
genetic - yeah bad Oh [ __ ] karma no
Matt I'm going in this time you better
believe it
I raped a woman and I'm going at
everyone is happy hi well yeah you're
right
it oh man why do you get summit okay
here's the Bulls cry don't even work
alright cool God - running run John oh
[ __ ] yes I make it Oh shining on the
tail holy SH a good you did get again
I'm stroking my jaw
nothing not all right oh yeah thing you
come up should follow them all right I'm
taking all out get them from the top
I'll get the left if you get the right
ear all right
one barrel down does barrel down up four
bucks just pray for me cry all right um
prayed for boots done thank you
hey you're welcome no it did not I diet
Ricky not did you get game over now
again we cannot get game come on take
about more dps cry
dammit alright more dots please by dots
I mean bullets oh come on why does he
die then I jumped as a bullet
alright keep shooting him I jumped into
the body - don't jump a bullet that's
the opposite of what knees I know that
one lifeblood cry I cannot die alright
don't yes we got him yeah come on I mean
oh yes hell yeah good are you crying oh
no emotional that's alright you got
really into it alright now we can now we
can I'm probably gonna cut until this
point so now it's okay yeah Hawking hang
at Hatfield deader oh okay
he's dick here's a day is it dick oh I
got a horse
you're always why my host pick no mine
is superior no - don't jump in inside
these now we can't that's it
what are you doing commander wait never
mind okay no I quit
Bob does not good he does terrible
all right I think that is it Adam I
don't want I don't want to do that again
okay from the example come on that was
pretty badass back in a month I was a
hero
all right try it I'll let you do a
crimando hot drop when life gives you
bullets
come on all brother every day
Karam oh no no no no no it's not normal
that don't turn on me no no sure blood
you should have all that you should love
that you should t-shirt you shooting you
shoot your shot you stupid [ __ ] you
should I